it's the most dramatic political turn of
events in decades
protesters have burned government
buildings taken over airports and torn
down statues
dozens have been killed and hundreds
more injured on both sides protesters
and police
now the kazakh president has asked
russia to send in troops on a
peacekeeping mission what started as an
economic protest has quickly developed
into something much bigger so what are
people protesting about in kazakhstan
what's russia got to do with it and what
could happen next
[Music]
kazakhstan was part of the soviet union
with other republics including russia
and ukraine until its collapse in 1991
when it became an independent state
that's when this man no sultan
nazarbayev took charge he ruled the
country for nearly 30 years before
handing the presidency to his chosen
successor qasim jomat takayev in 2019.
takayev has been in charge ever since
but many believe that it's still
nazarbayev and his powerful family who
pull the strings behind the scenes
but that all looks like it's changing
it started with the government removing
a cap on energy prices on new year's day
that led to a doubling in the price of
liquefied natural gas a cheap
alternative to petrol which a lot of
people in the poorer regions use to run
their cars
protests aren't that frequent in
kazakhstan but people took to the
streets over this price hike and over
other wider socioeconomic problems
and the unrest spread like lightning
with violent protests breaking out
across the country especially in the
commercial capital of almaty
government buildings were set on fire
protesters seized the airport
[Music]
and on the streets police fired live
rounds tear gas and stun grenades into
the crowds with casualties on both sides
the police have even joined in with some
protests as anger has been directed
towards the government
cries of chalkette or old man go have
been heard at the protests aimed at
nazarbayev
this bronze statue of him was even torn
down
this is undermining the whole government
and more importantly it's an attack on
our citizens who are asking me as head
of state to urgently help them take has
responded by sacking his government and
removing nazarbayev from his role as
head of the powerful security council
he's also reinstated the energy cap as
well as promising a cap on food and
electricity prices
but it's not clear if this will satisfy
the protesters
unrest has been simmering across
kazakhstan for decades and it's
difficult to see how the government will
stop it
and the president's next move has been
to call for help from neighbouring
countries calling what's happening a
terrorist threat
kazakhstan has requested military
assistance through an organization
called the csto the collective security
treaty organization a russian-led
defensive alliance a similar idea to
nato
the belarusian president alexander
lukashenko has discussed the situation
with his kazakh and russian counterparts
in a phone call and the white house has
urged restraint
but this kind of unrest is the stuff of
nightmares for vladimir putin he doesn't
want to see protesters gain the upper
hand in authoritarian states like his
own and he'll do his utmost to make sure
that they don't
so why does this all matter
these latest demonstrations are
important because until now the country
has been considered pretty stable if
still an authoritarian regime
but this unrest is a stark reminder for
neighbouring countries like russia of
how quickly the cracks can show
former soviet countries like kazakhstan
are still relatively closely aligned
with russia
this latest unrest follows similar
anti-government protests in belarus in
2020 and before that ukraine in 2013.
and if there's anything that vladimir
putin hates it's the idea of a color
revolution where the people force
concessions from their government